foreign
former president Barack Obama is
scolding liberals who don't like it when
journalists ask tough questions watch we
have tended at times on the Progressive
side
to tip into
kind of a scolding
social etiquette police and and virtue
you know
signaling there have been times where
reporters are asking questions that
don't fit the accepted narrative or are
inconvenient for progressives around
certain issues and just by raising the
question or pointing out facts that
don't fit the neat narrative we'll jump
on them and say yeah why are you you
know aiding those who are attacking us
and I do think it is important for us to
not fall into that trap but it looks
like President Biden isn't taking the
advice of his former boss listen to what
happened when the president got asked
this inconvenient in Obama's words
question
why do you ask such a dumb question
Richard
um what what kind of warning is former
president Obama sending to to the
president and to his own party about the
way that they are shutting people down
if they don't like the narrative or the
question that they've been asked look I
listen I think this was a very good uh
actual episode and it was a good chance
to listen to the president sort of
lament on his time at the White House as
well as his time post the White House
and in throughout the episode he talks
about this ideal of the entire political
system and how we are all engaged in
this in this polarization where we
listen to the loudest folks in the room
and often forget the middle I think at
this particular clip what we're taught
what he's talking about he's right I'm
not sure this was the best answer from
Joe Biden because I think Joe Biden's
answer could have been look you know my
son is a private citizen the house the
the house oversight committee says they
have this evidence I would urge them to
if they have it and they say they've got
all these facts to have a hearing they
could have just said of course I'm the
big guy can't you tell well no I said I
don't think I mean listen I think
there's been a lot of conjecture from
this committee this committee has spent
more time like I said in the last second
they spend more time on television than
actually in hearing rooms actually
subpoenaing people ask actually asking
the tough questions so I think the
president had an opportunity to call
this committee out and say listen if you
say you have this evidence have a
hearing I'll come down there my son will
come down there we'll testify
they're not touching it so they're never
going to get to that stage where they
can have hearings because they can't get
their hands on any of the evidence
because the laptop's been sitting there
for years and it's very comfortably off
the you know on the very least we've
seen this movie play out before this
happened a couple years ago when there
was this whole thing around Benghazi
Hillary Clinton went down there and
testified for 17 hours and nothing came
of it of course it didn't right there
was like oh all these crimes happened
she did all this stuff with Benghazi
yeah
yeah to send out some subpoenas and have
a hearing
around to the topic here you know Jesse
it made me think of the moment this week
when Korean Jean-Pierre just shut down
this e uh EWTN reporter who said you
know what do you say to parents who are
a little bit concerned about their
daughters playing sports with biological
males and that they might get hurt in
that situation we know that there's a
young woman who got a concussion and a
neck injury uh playing volleyball with a
biological boy
um and and she just like she said are
you suggesting that trans children are
dangerous like not like let me answer
your question she just shut him down
with a judgment on him and didn't answer
his question yeah so the Democrats are
just bullying reporters and now the
reporters are scared to ask questions
and if you're scared and you're working
you get hurt that's what they say in
football when you play scared you get
injured and that's what all these
reporters are doing they're all 30 years
old they're all looking for friends
they're all trying to build a career and
if you get ostracized by
Paris Jean-Pierre then you're going to
get scared and everyone's going to look
at you funny at the next briefing one
second Richard we'll get to the hearings
right now we're doing depositions and
we're doing subpoenas it's kind of
difficult when there's a cover-up going
on at the highest level you haven't seen
a subpoena oh you didn't see the Six
Million that they took from China that
you lied about let me finish Joe Biden
and Barack Obama have to understand this
Democrats aren't fun anymore and Obama's
a guy guys don't get offended when we're
around other guys it's only when the
girls come around that's what we pretend
that we're offended so we look sensitive
Michelle said the same thing she's like
you know what our daughters and their
friends they're kind of annoying they're
always trying to Word Check us like if
we say Indian instead of Native American
like you can't even have these people at
your company anymore they're gonna throw
you a lawsuit HR complaint they'll Bud
Light you it's really nerve-wracking you
know and people are now offended on
behalf of minorities half the time the
minorities aren't even that offended
it's a liberal white woman who's
offended on their behalf Richard and I
we're respectful enough towards each
other but Richard's not offended by me
I'm not sure
I don't think Richard really wants to
speech police me he probably wants
police reform Richard probably cares
about policy anything for me you can't
even talk about policy we're Democrats
documented migrant they just stopped the
conversation
you know it also shuts down like the the
poor reporter you never got an answer to
his question he just got like shut up
basically he was told shut up first of
all I think it's Rich for Barack Obama
who is the president who created this
division between the press and the White
House when he started trashing Fox News
and conservatives during his time as
president to come out and say you know
they shouldn't do this I'm happy he's
come out and said it I really am but it
makes me wonder why is he saying it is
this like a message to Joe like Joe get
off the stage or Joe you're being
ridiculous I don't know what his
motivation is there's a reason that he
did this
yeah at some point we'll figure out what
the reason is but um you know the the
getting joe off the stage I think is
ultimately what they all want to do I
think everyone recognizes that the
Democrats are vulnerable with Joe as a
candidate today for president who knows
what they're going to come up with and
you know what you can say yeah yeah
subpoena them this that and the other
thing they won't even answer a question
Joe was so out of control that's a bunch
of malarkey what a dumbass question look
at that SOB Peter Ducey give me a break
man this one's a pain in the neck
anytime you get close to an issue that
discusses or touches upon his uh uh
International
contacts through his son and the money
that's come in or the big guy that's
when he shuts everything down there's no
way he's going to admit or talk about
any of that and by the way 53 percent of
those who voted said they would have
changed their vote who voted for Biden
if they had known about the big guy and
he's just shutting it down at every turn
along with his lacking in Christopher
Ray the head of the FBI who wouldn't let
out at 10 23 which is an unpleasant
fight by Donald Trump well you know what
he's still there yeah that's right he's
still there under Joe Biden he worked
for Joe Biden and he will not let that
and did not want to let it out until
they threatened that they would hold him
in contempt of court because that 1023
has all the information they need to get
to the rest of the nine Banks and a an
insurance policy by a by a uh the the
president of barisma saying you got 5
million for me now you better deliver
that American policy Greg yes do you
have a question for me Martha I would be
interested in a question well you know
what do you think President Obama the
former president is getting at here why
is he calling out his own party for uh
basically shaming people if they're if
they're not on the on the same page this
is an excellent question because there's
a subtlety to this and then there's a
real thing that he's hitting it the
subtlety is he acknowledges that they're
all both on the same side that the press
and the the party are on the same side
and it and you know if you just like
give them a little slack it'll look
better right right it'll just be like
you've let them look like they're doing
their job yeah let them look like
they're doing their job and blah blah
blah but then he says you know we tend
to progressives at times virtue signal
uh and that I mean you got it's not a
lot but you got to take it right you got
to admit thank you yeah it's good he
underestimates the problem however
because the virtue signal and the
aggression is the only weapon that this
the Democrats use these days if you
disagree with them uh you will either be
a racist a homophobe a transphobe uh who
wants to ban books or whatever maybe
you're secretly a drag queen who knows
and you're right yeah yeah no I'm
talking about you and uh don't
don't gay shame people here what um and
he should really talk to his old VB
who's basically deep in the wounds since
he became elected this is a guy that was
supposed to unite the country I would
love for Joe Biden to finally say
this issue fill in the blank is not
about race he will never say that either
because he's incapable of completing a
full sentence or he isn't allowed to say
that as he said when he was talking
about the train over the Indian Ocean
yeah he says I better not go any four I
better not go any further I might get in
trouble yeah he told on himself he's not
in control of his words he's not allowed
to say things but at least Obama you
know I wish he would be more forceful
about this because this is a problem you
know he should say to his party lighten
up guys come on let's have some fun and
not everybody is a racist that should be
the T-shirt not everybody's a racist and
remember that David David Axelrod and
and President Obama did not want Joe
Biden to run David Axelrod said he was
like Mr Magoo wandering around the
debate stage they did not want this so
now they're continuing on this campaign
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else